we tested 50 pancake recipes and this is
the best one I love my pancakes light
fluffy with lots of flavor perfect to
start we like separating our egg yolks
and egg whites this gives our pancake
extra air bubbles helping it get even
more fluffier when it comes to pancake
batter lumps are okay don't worry they
will sort themselves out in the cooking
process over mixing leads to gluten
development creating a chewy pancake and
that is not what we're going for our
final tip let your pancake batter rest
for at least 15 minutes before you start
cooking this allows the flour to absorb
the liquid which is essential for
pancakes that are light and Airy the
rule of Pancakes is that the first one
always turns out ugly use that as a
tester it's only a pill after that